and make theid but the difference between three
minutes of course they would have stopped the
bus anyway turnover right Save Right P save
by Samson off his best save in the game punck
is still loose and the Bruins get back to it
here's lorite swings it for Carlo trying to set
they score H Saka in front of the net and it's
one nothing Boston Montgomery just changed the
Bruins lines he's got hen with zaka and po they
pulled the puck in the zone first NHL game first
NHL point for Mason lorai to get away from the
Matthews line here racing into the Toronto end
Maran wins the battle shut off the angle stop de
bruss on the loose chage loose pu and and we get a
whistle Riley turns it back on with a friend
good battle along the wall two on two in the
Lea s set in front oh what a save samsonov just
robbed Morgan geeky much more open than this as
van reight makes a slick pass here around John
kingberg and Samson off tracks it pushes off the
right post watch him push off that right post
and get out closer to geeki as geeki wants to
elevate this he doesn't quite get it up
as high as he wants but Samson off with
a Matthews can't handle their turned over to
Maran and the Bruins look to break back the
other way here's the brush it through big save
rebound score Jake de brush and Boston has a
two nothing [Applause] lead K the BR first
goal of the Season look how quickly the BS
get through the neutral zone though and even
though it's a two on three the Le have plenty
of people back in the zone there's lagers
and bro in decent position lagas gets feed
off and the Special Teams I made a living on
the power play it's fine so you're not going
to go for that okay here's lorai nice move got
it througha and it's stopped by samsonov what
a set up there for the youngster lorai thinking
about his second National Hockey League point I
uh I looked over at the Bruins bench and Jim
Montgomery had a big smile and the kind of a
little laugh as you looked over at Joe sacko who
runs the defenses I guess lorai is not nervous
anymore Leaf get to it yeah L lorai had a
great training camp here's Marner take the
break Let's It Go and he scores Mitch Marner Far
Side along the ice and the maple leaves are on the
board 99 points a year ago the long pass up
through the middle of the ice and as Carlo
commits to the middle Marner quickly shifts
back to the elide now he's got room to shoot
it he comes back to the middle oh that hit the
defenseman's stick that hit Lor Lor's stick take a
peek again here as Marner has the puck he's going
to cut to the middle got it across now for Marner
flon shot shoulder aside by Swan still kept in
Matthews rifles a one timer bang and just like
that it's a two2 hockey game Marner and Matthews
score to tie things [Applause] up 63 Seconds Apart
then Matthews who missed just moments earlier
from the slot the Leafs pressure the Puck it's
kept in by lag stop there zarus in front kner
another save by Swan loose P toar how did that
not go in maybe the stick there of pamp L in the
16 seconds as Toronto controls the Pu now they're
going to attack the front of the net and it's so
hard to cover everybody because the puck moves so
quickly tavarus gets that loose Puck and you're
going to watch him shoot this he's got a clean
look at in the Toronto Ed and finally Matthews for
Mar for turn the Fe neander shot oh what a stopped
there by Swan unbelievable passing by the map
leavs does not result in a goal Matthews rifles
it hits the glass Matthews might have caught
a stick up high underneath them again and dig
themselves back into the game now it's going to
be the Bruins turn to settle things down here's
that last chance on the power play unbelievable
Puck movement so quick from player to player and
KNE Lander makes this pass across and he I don't
know if he's expecting it to come back but he gets
he looked nervous for about 4 seconds yeah ycro
trying to step the he in back another safe by
Swan Jeremy Swan was perfect for POS that allowed
the Bruin to get out of his Zone Le come back the
other way here's centered in front KN couldn't
bury that one 30 seconds left long shot on
goal I thought it was a quiz it is but the game's
going on right now something Great's going to
happen any second like right here KNE Lander a
glove to the face from Carlo has to readjust the
bucket here's KS toward the front of that got
a shot away and nearly got it in it's into
the third W watch this out in the neutral
zone we're talking a lot of both Mason L
because he's really had an amazing night he
makes the play in the center of the ring and
then gets this chance where the puck bounces
off of Samson off gets it back for shaton as
Ray mentioned he'll run this power play the
ABS of ma one time maret is stop poo Let it
Fly and Samson on the big glove save getting
back to the start of the 2122 campaign really
good movement here on shaton Kirk and Mar
for catch now is moving into position and
the puck goes through to zaka to and Samson
moves all the way across neander loses to the
Bruins come back there's a return feed Heen
takes on his backand catches the pipe David
Pasto the bees look to come out Maran is
trailing here's the brus with a step finds
Maran in the slot and a glove save by Ila
Samson power play it was one and Samson off
Flash the GL here after by Jake the L not Jake
his kid is and here goes very good here's Jake
scores Jake the brus on the shootout they
gorgeous neander will hold this Puck as
long as he can he has a great backhand deep but
he can really shoot it there is the backhand de
and Swan denies him San's got great sze great
athleticism too and as he gets deeper into
the cre he's able to spread the right pad to
make the save here's Charlie Coyle for Boston
now he'll take his sweet time and scores
buries it on samsonov this must feel like
a whole different world for samsonov he hasn't
given up a goal in Forever in this game and now
he gives up two cole really patient and he's
going to jam this through the pads of Samson
off you see him shrug his shoulders he's
angry at himself that this goes through
now Austin Matthews hats the score San win it
here for Boston here's Matthews DS it through
the legs and wide through the legs of Swingman
and out the other side and it's all over and
the Bruins win in a shootout in Boston tonight
defeating the maple Lea three to2 in a thriller